Yeah.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today's topic is the languages of
Belgium.
When most people think of Belgium,
they think of Belgian chocolate,
Belgian waffles,
Belgian beer and things like that,
but there is much more to Belgium than
those things,
including a very interesting linguistic
situation.
First,
let's get some geographic perspective.
Belgium is located in western Europe,
bordering France to the south and
southwest Netherlands to the north and
northeast Germany to the east and
Luxembourg to the southeast.
This geographic location is reflected in
Belgium's linguistic diversity.
Belgium has three official languages,
Dutch,
which has historically been spoken by
the Flemish people,
French,
which has historically been spoken by
the balloon people and German.
These three languages ended up being a
part of this one country because of
Belgium's history.
The low countries which include Belgium,
the Netherlands and Luxembourg have been
strategically important throughout the
ages.
The low countries were ruled by a
succession of rulers.
Eventually coming under the rule of the
Spanish empire and 1556 and became
referred to as Spanish Netherlands.
The Dutch revolt of 1568 to 1581
resulted in the independence of the
northern provinces,
which became the Dutch republic,
which separated the Dutch from Belgium.
Even though the northern part of Belgium
spoke the same language with different
dialects.
Of course,
in 1713 after the Spanish war of
succession,
the Spanish Netherlands,
the southern part minus the Dutch
republic came under Austrian control.
Then in 1794 it came under French
control and soon after that the Dutch
republic was also brought under French
control.
After Napoleon's defeat the Napoleonic
wars,
the United Kingdom of the Netherlands
was created in 1815 which included
present they Netherlands,
Belgium,
as well as Luxembourg.
After the Belgian revolution of 1830 the
kingdom of Belgium was created with the
support of France.
At first,
Belgium was a single state with one
official language French.
Even though the majority of people were
not French speakers in the 20th century,
a series of changes resulted in a
federal system with three official
languages.
Dutch just spoken as a native language
by around 55% of the population and by
around 13% of the population as a second
language.
French is spoken as a native language by
approximately 36% of the population with
about 45% of the population speaking at
as a second language.
German is much less widely spoken as a
native language.
Then the other two by less than 1% what
around 22% of the population speak it as
a second language.
The three official languages are
generally concentrated in distinct
linguistic areas.
Dutch is the language of the Flanders
region in the north.
French is the primary language of the
Wallonia region to the south with German
being the primary language of some areas
of eastern Wallonia near the border with
Germany.
The Brussels Capitol region is
officially bilingual with Dutch and
French being the two languages.
There are no official statistics about
the number of speakers of each language
in the capital,
but it's quite obvious that French is
the predominant language.
The Belgian federal state consists of
three administrative regions,
Flanders,
Wallonia,
and the Brussels Capitol region,
as well as three federal communities
based on language.
The Flemish community has authority and
the Flemish provinces and in the
Brussels capitol region.
The French community has authority and
the balloon provinces,
with the exception of the German
speaking municipalities as well as in
the Brussels capitol region alongside
the Flemish communities and the German
speaking community has authority and the
German speaking municipalities of the
province of lineage in Wallonia.
The areas administered by the German
speaking community are the areas given
to Belgium by Germany in 1920 under the
treaty of Versailles,
the federal communities each have their
own government and parliament,
which are distinct from the regional
government and parliament.
The governments of the communities have
power over matters of culture,
education,
health services,
and social services.
That's in contrast with the regional
governments that have power over matters
of economy,
infrastructure,
town planning,
and so on and in the Brussels capitol
regions,
the Flemish and French community
governments and the regional government
are merged together into one within the
Flanders region.
Most municipalities offer services only
in Dutch and in the Wallonia region.
in French,
but there are some municipalities with
language facilities that also offer a
public services like schools and courts
in another language as well.
These municipalities are typically those
bordering a different linguistic area
administered by a different linguistic
community or bordering the Brussels
Capitol region.
There are 12 municipalities in flanders,
which offers services in French,
six of which have a French speaking
majority and in French speaking
Wallonia,
there are four municipalities offering
services in Dutch and two more offering
services in German and all of the
municipalities and the German speaking
part of Wallonia offer services in
French and in the Capitol region.
All services are offered in both French
and in Dutch.
And I should note that all federal
services are provided in all three
official languages at the national level
language varieties.
So we know that there are three official
languages with their respective
communities and areas,
but there's more to it than that.
One of the official languages is Dutch,
but is it the same as the Dutch spoken
in The Netherlands?
Well remember that a language normally
consists of a number of different
dialects that are usually united by a
common standard language.
The standard form of Dutch used in
Belgium is basically the same as the
standard form used in the Netherlands,
but the dialects that people grow up
speaking are different than those spoken
in the Netherlands and the different
quite a lot from each other as well.
The dialects of Dutch spoken and
flinders are often collectively referred
to as Flemish.
The main dialect groups are in and east,
Flemish and west.
Flemish and Limberg ish are sometimes
included as well.
Though these are often considered
distinct enough to be separate regional
languages.
Limburger cheese for example,
has some features that are closer to
German than other Dutch dialect.
For example,
personal pronouns that are similar to
the German ones like myth do this and so
on.
Exactly where to draw the boundaries of
a language and deciding which dialects
are included in that language is often a
tricky question.
There's no black and white distinction
between Dutch and German,
but rather there's a west Germanic
dialect continuum.
Spending a wide area and language
features gradually change as you move
along.
The continuum and the standard language
that a dialect is paired with often for
political reasons is a big factor in
what language or a dialect is considered
to belong to.
Of course the promotion of Standard
Dutch has caused Flemish dialects to
fade to some extent,
but some differences in vocabulary and
pronunciation remain.
There's also a new variety of Dutch that
has arisen called [inaudible].
It's basically a middle ground between
standard Dutch and Flemish dialects,
but from a lot of comments I've seen
online that seems like a lot of people
dislike this variety of Dutch.
They think it sounds artificial.
The situation with French is also
interesting.
Standard French is learned by everyone
in the French speaking areas,
but it's paired with traditional
dialects like walloon or while loan
peacock Sean Penn won and Loja,
which are arguably separate regional
languages.
They belonged to the longer boy in the
branch of the Gallo.
Romance languages as standard French
does,
but they are distinct from it.
These regional languages have,
for the most part been replaced by
standard French and are mainly spoken by
an aging population and particularly in
the countryside.
These lung,
the oil in Wallonia have not remained in
use as much as the Flemish dialects and
flenders have.
Why is that?
I think that's partly because during the
period of French rule when the use of
French was highly encouraged speakers of
closely related regional languages found
it much easier to adapt to French.
Then the speakers of Flemish dialects in
the north did and maybe because those
languages are so closely related to
French,
their speakers felt that they were just
making a small adjustment rather than
giving up something,
but that's my speculation as is the case
with Dutch and French.
Belgium has a number of dialects that
are considered to be a part of the
German language alongside standard
German.
The German dialects of the officially
German speaking areas are central German
dialects including Repu area in the
northern part of the area and Moselle
Franconia in the southern part of the
area.
These dialects differ significantly from
standard German,
but standard German has had an influence
on them resulting in some dialect
leveling,
meaning that the dialects are not as
different from standard German anymore
and not as different from each other
anymore and speakers up those dialects
use some French vocabulary in their
speech because of the influence of the
surrounding French speakers in the
Willow Nia region and I believe the
majority of German speakers are
bilingual and can speak French as well
because Belgium is part of a Germanic
dialect continuum.
There are a number of dialects that
don't clearly fall under any of the
three official languages.
One such language as low deach,
which is a number of transitional
dialects between Lindbergh Ish,
which is often considered a flemish
dialect and the rip you Arion dialect of
German.
It's spoken in a few towns and villages
in the municipality of open in the
German speaking part of the edge,
but rather than simply being considered
a dialect of German,
it's unique enough to be considered its
own regional language.
Certain varieties of low ditch are very
close to certain varieties of Limburg
ish,
which is sometimes considered a flemish
dialects,
a Dutch dialect,
but other varieties of low deach are
very close to certain varieties of
riparian which are considered varieties
of German classifying these very similar
dialects as different languages is one
of those confusing and mystifying
aspects of linguistics.
Then there's Luxembourg ish.
It's spoken in the Belgian province of
Luxembourg,
which has the same name as the
neighboring country.
Even though it's closely related to the
surrounding Moselle,
Franconia and German dialects.
It's not normally considered a dialect
of German.
That's partly because it has its own
standardized written form and it
speakers are not considered members of
the German speaking community but rather
speakers of a regional language.
The area in which Luxembourg she has
spoken is inside French speaking
Wallonia where Luxembourg ish is
recognized as a regional language,
but the use of Luxembourg ishe has
declined in favor of French.
Much of what I say in this section will
be based on comments that I've read
online written by a Belgian people and
comments I've heard from Belgian people
face to face.
As you can see from the statistics we
looked at earlier,
most Belgians can speak at least two of
the official languages at least to some
extent in particular Dutch speakers can
usually speak some French,
but according to a lot of comments that
I've read that some Dutch speakers are
reluctant to speak French,
especially in a Dutch speaking area.
It's quite common in bilingual places
for speakers of one language to resent
having to speak the other language if
they feel that their own language isn't
being given equal status.
French has traditionally been the higher
status language in Belgium and Dutch
speakers had to learn it in order to
advance in life for it to get a better
job than that kind of thing.
So maybe because of this sort of
historical rivalry there might be some
resistance to speaking French.
That's just my impression based on
things I've heard or read and I can't
exactly say for certain,
and these days,
English is becoming much more widely
used as a second language in flanders.
While French has declined,
some young people who speak mostly Dutch
and flanders might speak English when
they encounter a French speaker or when
they visit the bilingual city of
Brussels.
Education in Belgium is different
depending on the linguistic community
that administers that area.
In Flanders,
students begin learning French in the
fifth grade of elementary school and
then begin learning English in seventh
grade,
and some students take German or another
language later,
but there are students who complained
that the teaching methods emphasize
grammar and literacy rather than
communication,
which leaves them without enough
conversational confidence.
Wallonia some French speakers are also
bilingual French Dutch speakers,
but not as many of them.
But in recent decades,
more French speakers are learning Dutch
because of the growing economic
influence of Flanders.
The education system in Velonia offers a
choice between Dutch and English.
Many choose Dutch,
but again,
they don't necessarily learn to
communicate that well in the language.
A smaller but significant number,
learn German,
but outside of the border areas.
Few of them learn it to an advanced
level.
From what I hear and as in Flanders,
English is growing in popularity.
Brussels,
even though it's an enclave inside
Flanders,
Brussels is officially bilingual and
wild.
There are no official counts of who
speaks with language.
It's an overwhelmingly French speaking
city with many estimates saying it's
over 90% francophone.
Both French and Dutch schools are
available and each family can choose
which type of school to send their
children to regardless of what language
they speak at home and at shops and
restaurants.
Staff should be able to speak both
languages,
at least in theory,
but that's a major capital and as the de
facto capital of the European Union.
Brussels is a very international and
linguistically diverse place.
Many languages are spoken among the
expat communities with English serving
as a Lingua Franca alongside French.
There are also many immigrants.
In 2010 about 18% of the population of
Belgium was foreign born.
While in Brussels the number was around
33% many of these people and their
children are native speakers of
languages other than Dutch,
French and German.
From what I understand,
many of these people speak a foreign
language at home,
one of Belgium's official languages,
probably Dutch or French and in many
cases English as well.
The German speaking community because of
their proximity to French speaking
Wallonia and because French is a
required subject in schools,
in the German speaking community areas,
most German speakers can speak French as
well as German and from what I
understand,
many speak Dutch as well,
which is probably helped by the fact
that Dutch and German are closely
related media in Belgium.
The media in each linguistic area is
dominated by the language of that
region.
Each of the three linguistic communities
has its own public broadcasting
organization,
which is responsible for creating
content and administering radio and TV
stations and so on.
The result is that the members of each
linguistic community are primarily
exposed to only their own language
through the media.
The notable exception is Brussels,
where both the Flemish community and the
French speaking communities,
public broadcasting organizations
operate Belgium as an interesting case
because in some ways it operates like
three separate countries administered by
three different linguistic communities
with their own governments.
And the generally limited interaction
between flanders and Maloney up
reinforces the kind of linguistic divide
or separation.
But the majority of people speak two
official languages at least to some
extent,
and some of them speak three with a lot
of people learning English these days as
in many multilingual federations.
Some people speculate about whether the
country will fracture into separate
countries and there are disagreements
about how to handle the complex
governing of a federation with three
regional governments and three community
governments based on language in
addition to a federal government.
I can't claim to speak for Belgians,
but just from the comments that I've
read and heard,
it seems to me that Belgian people
identify more as Flemish or walloon or
as German speaking then as Belgium,
but they generally have no strong
objection to this federal system from
what I can see.
But this kind of situation reminds us
that languages are not just systems of
communication.
They are also part of people's
identities.
End of tremendous importance to people.
The question of the day for people from
Belgium,
what's your native language and to what
extent do you speak to the other
official languages and for other people?
Let me ask a more general question.
To what extent do you see your native
language as part of your identity?
For me as an English speaker from
Canada,
my language is not really a strong part
of my identity.
It just feels like the default,
but I know it's different for a lot of
people around the world.
How about you?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to my amazing patrion
supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen.
Who are my top tier patrion supporters?
Thank you for watching and have.